you know making resolutions at the start
of every new year is easy to do but not
so easy to keep so i went looking for
healthy habits that might be easier to
work into your life today we're tackling
getting a restful night's sleep which is
pretty challenging at times but i found
out it can be done with a little
consistent training
sleep is essential to human life i mean
it supports
every
organ system in our body i mean you know
we definitely wouldn't survive without
it sleep behavioral specialist sean the
gowda says our bodies and brains perform
critical healing during our rest at
night our brain we
remove a lot of waste and toxins when
we're sleeping
we
have there's a link between poor sleep
and cancer
our hormones and chemicals in our body
that are related with appetite are
impacted when we don't get sleep the
national sleep foundation recommends
seven to nine hours of sleep each night
for adults but let's face it that's not
always easy to achieve so how do we
train ourselves to be good sleepers i
think when people are really focusing on
trying to get good sleep um they tend to
think about
what am i doing around bedtime or in the
middle of the night or in the morning
and i like to remind people that we
should really be thinking about what am
i doing during the day one of the
biggest things that i promote is
physical activity another thing would be
your exposure to sunlight gowda says
getting sunlight in the morning sets our
internal master clock to keep us awake
and alert during the day but then take
in the sunset to wind down for bed so
that's why that dim light
is important because it sends a signal
to our clock
that it is evening time the sun is
setting it's really time to wind down
and it actually sends a signal to our
pineal gland which is what released his
melatonin a couple hours before bedtime
and that crucial melatonin to help us
sleep can be stifled by the bright blue
light of our tech devices too late at
night the blue light is that ray of
sunlight that is very much alerting and
telling our master clock to be awake
and unfortunately
a lot of our devices led lights all of
that has a lot of blue light gowda also
warns to avoid heavy meals several hours
before bed and make an educated decision
on alcohol one drink is shown to impact
your sleep at night even just one drink
at dinner can have a change in how you
naturally sort of cycle through your
sleep gowda ensures good sleep can come
when you create a desirable restful
environment set yourself up for success
in your bedroom so you know take some
time to declutter um you know have it be
a room that you're excited to go to um
not a room where you're thinking oh my
goodness i haven't put the laundry away
i'm making sure that it's really quiet
and really dark so whether that's
installing you know blackout shades um
using an eye mask a white noise machine
to you know kind of cover up any type of
noise that might be coming from the
outside or the neighbors
we're barking dogs all that well shantha
also says to keep the bedroom
temperature between 62 and 68 degrees
now that seems kind of chilly but it
does help you sleep better and if you
have to get up during the night or have
times when you wake up don't look at the
clock it just makes you anxious and
harder to fall back asleep and if you
have more serious sleep issues like
insomnia that don't get resolved with
some of these tips you better see a
sleep therapist sometimes it requires
medication a little extra yeah and some
people use over-the-counter aids like
either melatonin supplements or z-quilt
things like that she said see your
doctor about those first because those
could be habit-forming and sometimes you
can wake up not feeling so great in the
morning just kind of depends on the
person
so learned a lot of good information too
there's also a hormone hormone called
ghrelin
and that's our appetite hormone and she
says if you don't sleep get enough sleep
that appetite hormone gets all
discombobulated makes us hungry when
we're not supposed to be hungry we eat
more great thanks sherry ladies
get your sleep okay if that doesn't do
it you don't want your grilling growling
grill
[Laughter]
good advice oh so it affects so much of
our lives we have more reports this week
yes we do we're going to talk about
self-care
positive body talk the power of h2o and
making those moves
okay good stuff sheri i'm excited lots
of good stuff all right we got